GABRIELA D'AVILA FERRARA:
With almost 500 sessions
at Next 2019, it's
understandable
that you couldn't
get to them all.
So if you didn't see Tools
for Migrating your Databases
to Google Cloud,
then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this session, learn
about the options
to migrate your current workload
to Google Cloud Platform
and ways that you can
minimize the disruption
that a migration can cause.
You will learn about
three steps for migration.
First is the assessment
to figure out what to move
and if it is ready to be
moved, as well to learn
about the new path
to the cloud and how
the support for that
workload would be.
Second is the migration itself.
If this will be a simple
rehost or complete rewrite--
it will depend on your needs.
And third is the tuning
and optimization part.
How do I get better,
faster, and cheaper?
To help with all
of those steps, we
have migration partners, which
we showcased in this session,
to help you achieve either
your homogeneous migration--
for instance, MySQL to Cloud
SQL or HBase to Cloud Bigtable,
or if it is a
heterogeneous migration,
like Oracle to
Cloud SQL Postgres.
This session also shows how
a migration to Cloud SQL
can be done by yourself.
And this could happen
mainly in two ways--
a simple approach or a
minimum downtime approach.
If you can afford
downtime and this
won't affect your business, you
can go through the simple route
by doing an offline
migration where
you get all your
data into a dump file
and import it to a new
Cloud SQL instance.
Once this phase is
completed, then you
can put all systems
online again.
If your application cannot
take a significant downtime,
then another solution that
we have is using Cloud SQL
as an external replica
to your primary server.
The way this works
is by spinning up
a new instance of Cloud
SQL, using the Migrate Data
option in reference to
your primary server.
That way, replication
will start and catch up.
Meaning that every change you
made in your previous server
will be applied to the new
one on Google Cloud Platform.
Once replication
gets up, it is time
to do the work of stopping
replication, promoting
your replica to primary, and
making sure your application is
aware of the new
server to be able to do
reads and writes on the
new Cloud SQL instance.
The effective time
taken on this model
will depend on a few variables
that this session explains,
such as DNS propagation.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]